[音楽]
ストリングカルテットの音が
世界最大の沈むことのできない
ライナータイタニックを旅する気分のファン
多くの人々が海の真ん中で道を忘れて
幸せに
踊っています 氷山に衝突して
沈没し始めた
が、全員に十分な救命ボートがなかっ
たため、
2,200人のうち約1500人が海底に沈んだ。
なぜ彼らは十分な救命ボートを持っていなかったのか。
今日
は正常性バイアス
が私たちに与える影響についてお話ししたいと思いますので、
緊急事態が発生したときに身を守るためのヒントをお伝えします
防災
システム研究所は正常性バイアス
を人間の本能として定義し
、脳を防ぐために緊急事態を過小評価
しています
この偏見のためにすべての事故に飽きて、私たちは
時々駅は危険ではないと思います
、そしてティタが私たちに何も起こらない
nicは
、タイタニックがこのアイデアを沈めることは決してないと信じていたため
、人々は十分な救命ボートを積まなかったようになり
ました。
2011年3月11日に日本以上
で津波警報が発令された後、大地震が発生するが、
70％の人が家にいる危険性を知っていた
が、ほとんどの
人は津波は襲わない
と思っていた。
他の人がこの偏見を逃れなかったので大丈夫かもしれません私たちは
適切な判断を却下します慈悲の
偏見は私たちの最高の時間を悪夢に変えることができ
ます
2015年の最終日、私は
母と一緒にユング花火でドイツにいました。母は
私を行かせようとしましたが、
誰かが
叫んでいて酔っ払った人がたくさんいたのでホテルに戻りました。
しかし、私は彼女に注意を払わず
、他の消防車でひどい経験
をしてしまい、財布を盗もうとしました。状況は明らかに危険でしたが、それは恐ろしい瞬間でした。
ホテルへの偏見が私の最高の時間を悪夢に変えたことを後悔している
あなたはキックが起こらないような同じような経験をするかもしれません
安定した存在
は誰もが慈悲の偏見を持っていませんか
それは確かに私たちの行動に影響
を及ぼします
正常性バイアスは人間の本能であるため、自分自身を守るために
それを完全に取り除くことは困難ですが、
この本能をある程度制御して
このバイアスを減らすことができますバイアス
に対する抗体を取得する必要があります ■
それが得られない限り、あなたは自分で殺され
ます。どうすれば抗体を手に入れることができますか？私の
提案は、もし質問があればどうなるか
を
尋ねることです。 爆発の
音がもっと難しいのは何ですか？
ニュースで見ているときやよく
わからない場所に行ったときに
、
私たちが得る状況をシミュレートすることで、どのような危険がありますか？ バイアスに対する抗体で
あり
、緊急事態が実際に発生したときに危険な状況に直面する可能性が低く
なり
ます。他の人がしていることではなく、現在起こっていることをまとめることに焦点を当てることが重要
です。この状況が実際に起こっているかどうかを自問してください。
危険なこの
質問が鍵となります。なぜなら、大きな音や前夜などの異常なこと
を考えるようになったバイアスについて知った後、誰もが落ち着いて行動し、適切な決定を下せることを知っているから
です。
n危険に関連して少し早く、
私が言っていない質問
がどこにも行かないか、何もしない場合はどうなる
かを自問してみてください。
-
緊急事態に対してこれまでになく簡単に何をすべきかを質問できれ
ば、その日の日本自然災害科学協会によると、ある
都市の1つの都市
で、都市の子供たちの命の99.8％を救うことができます。
世代を超えて受け継がれてきた
津波天伝
という言葉があります。これ
は、人ができるだけ早く海から逃げ出し、
命を救うという言葉に基づいて、アスリートが起こったときに他人を気にせずに
暴走することを意味します。
この言葉に疑問が根底にあるとしたら、
津波とは実際に家にやってくるの
か、誰かに指示を待っている間に逃げるのか、ということです。
この
人々は、その日の緊急事態の下で何をすべきかを知っていたのか、
結果が決まっていなかったの
か、すべてが急速に変化する今日の社会で殺人者から命を救うための鍵だったとし
たら、この安全な国で何か危険なことが起こる可能性があり
ます 日本では
前例のないテロ行為が
大規模に多くの国で起こっています
日本はまた
、他の国よりも自然災害に見舞われる可能性があります
事故災害に巻き込まれた後、過去は
私たちに教えてくれますニュースはこのスピーチで私たちに教え
てくれます